avanzamos en adelaida australia la
nadadora y arnet y pulso recordada por
haber vencido al estadounidense katy
desde que en la final de los 400 metros
libres se impuso en con una nueva marca
en la distancia al fijar el crono en
tres minutos 56 segundos con 40
centésimas 6 centésimas menos que el
registro del edex establecido en los
juegos olímpicos de río en el año 2016
omar qué significa esto para la carrera
de titus y también lo importante que es
para ella no participar en los
campeonatos de budapest pero sí
enfocarse en los juegos de la
mancomunidad británica
ella bueno primero hay que hay que
relativizar de pronto uno podría decir
que digamos poca la mejoría con respecto
al récord mundial que tenía
de aquí porque fueron solamente seis
centésimas
pero hay que pensar en lo que era su
marca personal con la que ganó en los
juegos olímpicos de tokio que está
mejorando en casi tres décimas completas
porque ya tenía 356 69 que fue con lo
que triunfó en aquella oportunidad luego
pensar en la longevidad del récord
porque el récord tenía 6 años ya de
haber sido impuesto y como decías de un
comienzo de campaña extraordinario en
este evento que es clasificatorio para
el campeonato del mundo de budapest y
fue en su caso como como lo mencionaba
no lo va a hacer pero en otros si sirvió
para definir cosas interesantes es tan
competitivo solamente australiano el
campeonato nacional australianos que
esos no se impuso uno solo se impusieron
dos récord mundiales porque es a esto
stick book impulso el de 200 pecho
y pues se desveló también un gran
misterio que se mantenía dentro de la
natación australiana que era si el astro
pop actor y cantante
cody simpson iba a poder nadar el
mundial finalmente no va a poder porque
decidió caer chambers que si va a
competir en todas las pruebas de
mariposa y así pasamos a la artritis muy
mal porque se cumplió en la segunda
parada de la time light de la disciplina
y entre los muchos resultados destaca el
triunfo de la británica tina a jr smith
en los 100 metros lisos y omar
importante este triunfo para ella y ya
anunció que quiere defender el título en
los campeonatos del mundo pero en este
caso en los 200 metros sí importante que
hayan brillado en casa además dos
figuras como teenage permite 6 smith que
le gana a la medallista de bronce de los
juegos olímpicos striker jackson que fue
la segunda en esta oportunidad y otro
triunfo importante aparte del de dina
que que le enfila bien de cara al
mundial de oregón
de kylie hopkinson es la figura
emergente de los 800 metros una prueba
donde se abren muchos resquicios luego
de la salida de las africanas que
normalmente lo estaban dominando ghana
kingson con 158 63 con parciales
extraordinarios 59 en los 400 segundos
128 en los 400 metros 128 en los 600
metros y eso la perfila bien de cara a
la rivalidad con la que será digamos su
principal
contendora en el mundial que con la que
se va a enfrentar la semana que viene y
sin mí la estadounidense y campeona
olímpica y otras dos cosas interesantes
que pasaron en esta prueba en este
válida de la diamond league en el
birmingham fue el triunfo del esloveno
kristian che en el disco con 71 27 que
es la décima mejor marca de todos los
tiempos y el encuentro entre los dos
últimos campeones de los 110 metros con
vallas haslip artium en el vigente
vuelve a derrotar a su maestro omar
makled los dos jamaiquinos
13 09 para hansel vargas min 13 17 para
macri y en el caso de las atletas de los
800 metros de kylie regresa de una
lesión que no le permitió estar presente
en el campeonato del mundo bajo techo
pero hablemos también del campeonato
iberoamericano donde además españa que
ganó el torneo una gran actuación de
república dominicana impresionante
españa como decías gana pero dominicana
queda por encima de cube por encima de
brasil que son las dos grandes potencias
de estas otras dos grandes potencias
junto con españa de esta región una raza
impresionante en la velocidad ganan el
4% femenino el 4 por 400 masculinos
ganan tres medallas de oro en velocidad
con 12 en los 200 metros alex ogando
jean carlos martínez segundo en los 400
masculinos libios feliz primero luguelin
santos subcampeón olímpico queda segundo
y marc el audi mar y leidy paulino
subcampeona olímpica ganó los 400 por
encima
flor de lissa coffey
que es la otra integrante del 4 por 400
femenino y la otra gran estrella de la
velocidad y además con un 49 49 que la
convierte en líder de la mejor marca
mundial de todo el año para esta
dominicana y nuevo récord del campeonato
iberoamericano sumar muchísimas gracias
por ofrecer este amplio análisis hoy de
natación y atletismo durante la jornada
del fin de semana un placer